five Aryan hello rejects its Greg alpha
here with Morgan Han no Nicholas Cage's
in the room okay over your mind one I
don't bore your hand Ashley at nur how
to's the Morgan and actually is their
channel I have a video that was uploaded
on there recently over there with them
where I learn how to make a patriotic
blue thing on getting Jerome bi whatever
there you go that's a great goal
oh yeah thank you every once in a while
there's these things called ads on
YouTube as don't pay people anymore
but anyway five years commercial ads
ever found on YouTube number 205 unknown
it's eerie
are you not scary are you gals ready
let's go see ya love this channel I know
sometimes they do out our video most
television commercials are typically
created to sell product or have a spy
into an idea now there some achieve this
in rather mysterious ways number five
Japanese Kleenex commercial Oscars
commercial is an absolute classic and
sure we'll see you've seen already
quarter you may not know the story
surrounding claiming that the commercial
was actually cursed watch this
commercial pull up and we'll dive into
but you don't win shiny people
[Music]
chuckles baby pictures
ah this 30-second ad is for Kleenex
tissues and Erin only in Japan in 1986
the app depicts a rather strange scene
of a woman dressed in white who is
playing with a red painted baby on
ominous tune plays in the background
because of this many people are
convinced this commercial is haunted and
say that it may be connected to multiple
deaths after a recording of the average
posted to YouTube in May of 2006
multiple viewers have reported
experiencing frightening phenomena when
the clip displayed at the stroke of
midnight a YouTube channel shrouded hand
use the phone camera to record the video
off of a TV MA at exactly 12:00 a.m.
midnight following clip is what they
shared the following day no no no great
I love so like this
cRIO
no actually
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
oh my god no those cannot be real here's
what we know for sure about the
commercial this is one of different
Kleenex ads created for Japanese TV and
1986 the woman in the video is a
well-known Japanese actress Keiko
Matsuzaka and the oddly dressed baby is
made up as a deer presumably from
Japanese mythology apparently people are
claiming that the actress the baby and
many of the production team died shortly
after appearing yeah Matsuzaka is still
alive and well today I'm sure many of
the staff additional innocence and
playing in the background adds everyone
up in arms is an old European to called
it's a fine day written by Edward Martin
however some still claim that watching
the video at midnight cost some viewers
to go insane or commit suicide which
actually may be true there's a fair
amount of evidence supporting this claim
which is truly chilling number four are
you clear do you wanna have the Anakin I
talked about the following ad was
created to demonstrate the calming
effect of her Barrio teeth and it
certainly does this in a very
eye-catching way check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like their monsters horrible accident oh
it's calming down the sponsor that's
highlighted an actor key is the last
thing you expect to Cosmetics what the
commercial appropriately titled fears
does just that The Huffington Post
claims the contract of threatening
imagery in an act of calming tea is
supposed to make the viewer realize how
much they need rhubari
what do you think was this a defective
for you well I've never been called me
and because of it number sweet Ronald
McDonald's first television appearance
Oh God now that is from 1963 but the
goal rediscovered and uploaded to
YouTube in 2015 his version of Ronald
McDonald is a far cry from the Ronald we
all recognize today and why does he have
a drink cup for a nose take a look I
scared well do you thing the world's
ills silliest and Limburger eating is
wrong
Ronald let go hey roll your Impa isn't
watching TV but not many got delicious
McDonald's hamburger I know we're going
to be pretty good I can do everything
boys and girls like to do first thing
when it comes beat those delicious
McDonald's every imagine three your
people over why the gulfam burgers fries
the milkshake
[Music]
and this version of Ronald was played by
Willard's shot it eventually became a
weatherman for MBC today Reynolds has
been played by about ten different
actors since 1963 but this Ronald is
definitely the Caribbeans thankfully
wrong with his undergone many makeover
since this commercial and in 2004
McDonald's unveiled a much more have a
life with a self-proclaimed
active lifestyle investor however the
Ronald character came under fire in 2011
but over 500 health professionals wrote
an open letter to McDonald's insisting
they combat obesity by ditching the
clown and tire not sure what clown has
to do with obesity but it's no
coincidence that Ronald's appearance in
the u.s. act as lesson number two oh my
god is abs for windows 1971 train huh
and it's not a day in your kids ever
need to see a horror movie style editing
accompanied by a deranged voiceover
certainly evokes an uneasy feel but
there's something even more freaky than
a baby laughs alot and that's a baby
laughs a lot whose batteries are running
low watch this it's be laughs a lot and
her batteries are running down which is
what she sounds like
oh geez oh my god baby laughs laughs
haven't introduced for over 40 ah
number one Japanese McDonald's
commercial capital japanese we've seen
terrifying Japanese commercials and
terrifying McDonalds commercials or the
together is mentally like what was this
level of uh whoa when you economy is so
scary
oh my god this ad was released in 2011
and as it turns out this ad is actually
a fan-made which is kind of a relief
weary rather terrified that the team of
writers members to sit down and somehow
come up with its horrify the video liner
marketing's what do you guys think about
these collars philosophy what's going to
express so much for watching if you want
the while endeavor to be here I did I
answer those Elijah not all suddenly get
somebody now made like a YouTube thing
of like any night like Burger King made
it creepy right yeah that still is
creepy though
well the first one okay I'm so much to
say about it here we go oh it's a
subscriber five unknowns bring together
another fantastic video but actually
please continue this little first one
was by far the scariest with this red
demon baby and I just don't like unique
that really happen in midnight yeah she
you watch it on the pallet and there are
a lot of people ya find out do reactions
you guys want someone you don't worry B
is that there was literally a face in it
I want to go back every watching I was
kind of building my eyes I don't watch
his own yeah do it try it at midnight so
why would they why wasn't Kleenex hat no
but I think maybe they were trying to do
that thing why would they do this Gary
what do you think all I do yeah I don't
even get at that point yeah like like at
least the t1 like it made sense like it
was crazy but like I understood where
they were going just like I know who and
why wait it wasn't subliminal messaging
that was for the exact one why'd she
call me the demon child who looks a
little bit like a tin balloon maybe
that's argument or maybe that's her kid
and she's so upset that that's what
happened yeah she had a kid that she
needs Kleenex because she cried all that
she cries are the baby cries and the
Kleenex can help reverse the baby from
being a crying demon back to yeah we're
right nothing a midnight I don't know if
that was scarier than the crazy that
scares me so much I do want to go back
and there were a force of like people
committing suicide from it they said
there's a lot of evidence which is also
disturbing I said number five is usually
one that number one nothing Bad's gonna
happen to us we watched it though right
at midnight is when we don't want to do
that watching 24 hour
I guess harvest like I am value my life
I'm so sorry that I watched that I think
they can make a war movie a song it's
called the ring the trailer for the
calming tea that one actually made sense
cool I thought it was funny to me yeah
because it's like that's a very sweet
person to get it for you right did not
end like let's just say we were watching
a show at home and that popped on like
it would totally grab my attention I
think Oh crappy
well I think it was like an homage to
horror movies because they had like a
clown look like Pennywise the clown and
they had a chainsaw there that I thought
was referencing you know leather
from Texas Chainsaw Massacre hey that
kinda in a horror movie omage and
another commercial make sense you know
you get some calming tea to calm down to
seamlessly it was like beautifully shot
yeah it was really sure yeah
but respect an EXO was weird anything on
the back and the humid up here his voice
a little too deep the kid for some
reason just like older footage was a
sound of like that like popping dude I
mean that dozens with it's super creepy
for quality no for me like it's just
it's not so much him but it's like the
setting and like the sound of it yeah I
have any in the entire imagery behind
capturing if we have we got this clown
in front of like a artists camera right
here probably wouldn't have been in all
right here that I think this is the
nicest looking car I've ever seen
why did a couple is noble because he's
wrong Donald clown fast food like a
happy beautiful see you like the clown
this our eyes the clown's freaky
I don't like well my job like I thought
it was going to
hey boy I feel like he looks like a
pedophile totally well not as much about
the other one does the new ones you know
be the one and then when they were doing
the panning thing or the wariness was
the nice 80s clown looks like he's
freaking at it and he's like you know
been to jail and was an alcohol I think
that nineteen seventy one o'clock no
knockout no look at mine today
Rama Dali break-in at that's like
criminal wanna go away you why are they
saying with the new one is more athletic
looking he looks like he's wearing the
same thing as a last one I didn't
realize that they are you know their
shoulders are marked out how is that why
I guess basically a little slimmer
I don't know I can't tell I don't know
what is going on a very creepy
Ronald McDonald should not exist it
stuck to the point of him yeah he is a
hamburger a hamburger that's cute though
their big purple one to for a blob it's
called Barney dinosaurs wholly separate
branch
oh yeah they're having like a purple
table party yeah there's like little
McDonald's characters another purple
yeah I don't judge a mouse with pizza no
no he's a wrap on Dec review I don't
anybody Matt why what do you make a
clown a mascot I mean let's be real
there's so many people to have a scary
thing of clowns I found for Bailey
so why would you make your mascot a
clown because it show me who the head
that I think the clamping was invented
though when clowns are still liked
clowns are fun like this is in the 60s
or 50s and red is the color that
promotes hunger all right nice is this
laughing baby the laughing baby one I
could see Ashley and we're starring in a
commercial I did what dolls are one of
my like Spears and like heavy cannot
only the silence yes that silence is a
silence that movie scares me so much cuz
it's a little little of soul
ventriloquist uh-huh yeah and dolls
freak me out and this one is I mean it's
all not cute I could see the two girls
in the commercial being on day we should
reshoot this much on me yeah we have to
it with your laugh laughing so you're
lab over army oh my god dragon would be
like damn monkey organ sounds so scary
when the batteries are down like oh yeah
so I'm or you'll be on
like the movie Annabelle like supposedly
spirits attach themselves to dolls
yeah good spirits are dumb yeah don't
what about a lot of hot figures out
there kind of got the Fermi bags in this
purse whatever you a very unfortunate
spirit it's just hair is just sizzled -
I like the cookies I find some
commercial at IRL I like this doll it
was the one of the commercial is our
super look like this she looks a little
bit more obvious Julia Cole I like these
fan made of Ronald McDonald Japanese who
they are freaky old Harry I wish I knew
what they were saying in Japanese what
are they saying there's a channel called
raka raka that I got to show you guys
that they have a wrong McDonald serial
killer and gross character not analogous
so no it's like a it's like a spoof it's
like a reoccurring character they have
it's working outside kind of wants me
Tom oh you know what I told you I had
McDonald's today you did and I'm crazy I
told you I wish I had been there to
watch I read in now how has a coca-cola
c'mere cokes the better and I've hot
fudge sundae and maybe an apple pie her
the never was a McDonald again after one
I wasn't around much beer I think is the
scariest of all these little montage G
thingies I'm still reserved event no but
tell me the scariest when I was when the
phone rings and it pans down and he's
watching her Hatters that mrs. Tom and
the hand twins are unlocking yeah
yeah Wow sexy Oh God past reductive man
1 no matter I totally didn't get though
why would he just be running he's
running away to show you that McDonald's
helps enhance your energy have Leduc
strength ability to hold the crop and
he's running away
well guys those are some 5 eerie
commercial ads thank you your top 5
unknowns for introducing this to us you
guys Rock subscribe to the free old
rejects click that notification Bella
get notified every time one of our
videos is up while you're at it go check
it on how to use is Morgan an athlete
yeah go check them out on the social
media and stuff check out that video
where they teach me how to make
punch-drunk love and also being
reenactment much truncal up check out
our patreon for all exclusive goodies
good day to you America today and up all
the other countries that watch